steven guilbeault je déclare fidélité et
sincère allégeance la nomination de
steven guilbeault à la tête de
patrimoine canadien en avait surpris
plus d'un cinq mois plus tard lui qui
était surtout connu pour son engagement
écologique s'est retrouvé confronté à la
crise qui a affronté au ministre du
patrimoine
un baptême de feu adresse ses premiers
mois en politique là je sais pas combien
de temps pourrait durer ma carrière
politique mais ça risque de ressembler à
un long fleuve tranquille après cette
arrivée en politique avec tous ces
événements là la pandémie a heurté de
plein fouet le secteur culturel
les conséquences seront lourdes étant
donné qu'on n'a pas vraiment d'horizon
de prévisibilité sur le nombre de mois
que les salles de spectacles vont devoir
rester fermés ici il ya une possibilité
d'ouvrir dès cet été c'est une chose si
on ne devrait pas en décembre 2005 est
une autre l'industrie audiovisuelle a
elle aussi écopé de la crise occasionnée
par le corona virus et devra
impérativement se transformer son n'est
pas en mesure de reprendre dans les
prochaines semaines oui ça va avoir un
impact catastrophique il ya environ 130
production qui ont été arrêtés il faut
aussi s'assurer que le public ait un
accès à du contenu aux étrangers le
ministre affirme être bien conscient de
l'ampleur de la crise et du fait que la
donne a changé
on a amorcé une discussion avec avec
certains des acteurs du milieu pour
commencer ensemble à imaginer réfléchir
à quoi pourrait ressembler l'après crise
mais sincèrement j'ai pas j'ai pas de
réponse je pense que personne ne les
hommes en plus de la crise du
coronavirus le ministre doit jongler
avec la réforme du crtc le dossier des
gares faé la taxe netflix des dossiers
qui avait donné du fil à retordre à ses
prédécesseurs virage numérique accéléré
par la crise lakovic 19
je serai qu'on fait la démonstration par
mille à l'heure actuelle que beaucoup de
choses vont se dématérialise nous on
était beaucoup dans l'est la beauté de
ces changements l'eau mais aussi dans le
pire de ces changements là je pense que
l'eau il faudrait que le balancier se
repositionne sur ce point il reste ferme
sur son engagement
je m'étais engagé cet engagement là je
le maintiens de déposer un projet de loi
pour faire en sorte que les grandes
plateformes
participent de façon équitable au
financement du contenu culturel
québécois et canadien une chose est sûre
il faudra du temps et de l'argent pour
que le secteur retrouve son équilibre et
reprenne son erre d'aller
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal